5 43 here on a friday morning alex have
you confirmed
your valentine's day plans yet because
if not
you have to act fast valentine's day
alex is on sunday
yeah definitely with reservations right
now too and social distancing is forcing
singles to think outside the box
bianca holman shares how to make the
most of it
[Applause]
got an empty seat next to you this is
for all my singles and those in long
distance relationships
grab something with bubbles some
chocolate and your computer
this is valentine's day covet style to
swipe left
or swipe right that's a big choice for
people looking for bay on a dating app
match group the parent company for 45
dating brands including tinder and hinge
reported a 15 increase in august of 2020
downloads and subscribers
from pre-covered 2019 levels we spoke
with amy lettingham the dating coach
about the difference of virtual dates
now compared to just a year ago
new people are actually willing to try
it they're not
so it's not so taboo to do online dating
anymore social distancing restrictions
can make it harder to evolve a
connection built online
but it gives you time to understand your
crush's character and weed out the pen
pals
if somebody's on there for weeks and
weeks and they're not trying to
move it to a telephone call or even a
video date
or even asking to meet in person that's
a red flag here are a few virtual date
ideas
what's more romantic than a museum tour
the smithsonian's natural history has a
guided walk-through experience
you can go classic with a virtual dinner
and concert
many of your favorite artists have
performances on streaming platforms
and tap into your inner child and play
an online game of clue or battleship
with your sweetie pie
one of the things that i've been hearing
from the singles i work with is they do
love the zoom date
it almost saves them a drive it saves
them dinner
it saves them getting all done up
and then feeling like oh crap you know
this didn't work out
while dating has become more efficient
lettingham says people still crave human
connection
and the future of love and romance looks
bright people are taking dating more
seriously i
actually think we're going back to the
old-fashioned ways which
i don't have a problem with at all and
if you plan to meet in person
lettingham says keep safety at the top
of mind and meet in a public place
bianca holman 8 news now